Hey, what's going on? It's spill. Burn
his time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday, Monday morning
podcast and Ah, I'm checking in on.
Yeah, I'm just checking in on you.
I really need to check in on you.
At least half of you. A little
less than half old jeans, shoes.
Make sure you guys are right. There's
a lot of crying going on out there.
Jesus fucking Christ.
I've never seen so many fucking
adults crying in my life.
What is with all the fucking crying?
I get it. Your person didn't win,
but Jesus Christ,
you're making the left look horrible.
Going to Canada.
I love this shit where people
like threatening like share,
share goes, if Trump wins, I'm going to
go to Canada. It's like, who gives a fuck?
You know?
I don't even know you were still here.
Look, I'm not saying I'm happy. I wasn't
happy with either one of these people.
Right?
Um,
but the level of fucking arrogance of
celebrities during all of this shit was
just, it's such a, a whole other level.
Do you realize how fucking arrogant
you are that you're making this?
You basically, you're threatening that
if, if your candidate doesn't get in,
your going to leave the country
and your ego is so fucking big.
You think somebody going like,
well, I want to vote for Trump,
but if he gets elected,
we lose share.
Okay,
I got you babe.
The Fuck Outta here.
Heard Barbara Streisand.
Really?
You're going to leave fucking
Malibu to go live in Manitoba.
Railey you fucking
go ahead and do it.
I'll give you 40 bucks for your house.
They don't only get yet that 9,000
fucking acres up there. Go ahead. Go, go,
move up to yellow knife.
The dumbest shit.
But I literally think like that's the
level of ego that you have to have as like
an actor or a comedian or something like
that. Literally too. I mean, I know,
I guess I talk about it,
but you know, I fuck around.
I trashed replied now I told you
guys who to vote for or whatever.
I just trashed them both.
I tried to evenly,
but that fucking level that people take
it to where they just start. Uh, you know,
I kinda of was, I was on
Conan last night, which was a,
it was a really difficult show
to do last night because, uh,
you know, you know, people are like
fucking stunned out here. They can,
they can't believe it, um, as, I can't
believe it in San Francisco, Berkeley,
fucking New York City and
all that type of shit. Um,
so it was kind of weird. I, it was like
going on like right after a funeral.
I felt so. Um, but, uh, I really
think this is just my own opinion.
What do you guys, what do you guys
think about celebrities endorsing a,
uh, a candidate? Because
I think the candidates,
they also kind of reach out to
people a little bit. Like I, like, I,
I've never understood that. Like,
why would I be like, you know,
who was some of the people,
you know,
some of the fucking people
that have done it. Like I just,
I just don't understand. It's, Oh you
know I was going to vote this way.
But the guy from my three kings told me
to do all the other movie where he tries
to get the sky miles.
The Guy who did the movie about this
guy getting the sky miles is telling me
this should be the person
to lead the free world.
You know I got a lot of
feelings are not gun control,
but let me check in with Sean Penn first.
See what he has to say.
The level of fucking arrogance
that you have to have. I don't know. It's
a fine line cause it's like, all right,
well it's good that they're involved
politically, but like you know,
there's a lot that once you're famous
then they're actually going to put a
camera on you, then you're going to start
talking. You know, it's the same thing.
It's when you become a huge
fan of your team. You're,
you're a big fan of your
team, right? And you know,
you're always sitting up in the nosebleeds
and then all of a sudden you get a
part on a Sitcom and then they got you
sitting down there and then your team's
doing well.
And next thing you know,
this sticking the microphone
in the face of an actor, right?
To be or not to be a,
what do you think buffalo has to
do here in the second half? Well,
he took like to see you have your
checking down a little bit. It's like,
I don't, I don't understand. I mean it's,
you know what, in defense of celebrities,
regular people do the same thing on the
news and they get away with it cause you
don't know what their names are. You
see it all the time on these, uh,
you know, when you watched the news, if
he ever watched the news, they always go,
yeah,
we went out on the street to ask people
what they thought about this new target
that's going on. I think it's going
to take away jobs. You know what,
just think to downtown area, we don't
need that. There's always that fucker
Parson. Right. So maybe that's what it is.
That's that person is no different than
any of those other people. It's just,
I don't know.
I think once you get to a certain level,
you kind of need to
gracefully shut the fuck up.
All right.
Having said that,
has anybody explained to me why they're
making such a big deal about the
transition of power
here is far as you know,
we hope that it's going to be graceful
and we hope that it's going to be the,
when Obama came in, George Bush
was very graceful, gracious.
He was very blood. They all, they all
were my entire life. I've never, you know,
Reagan did knock on the White House
door and Jimmy was just like, Hey,
get the fuck out here.
There's literally camera's on.
That's another thing too.
There's cameras filming you
as this transition happens.
Everybody, everybody's always, you
know, you're going to be grace gracious.
They know we'll look, you know, they
don't like each other. You know,
this one's going to be particularly
fucking weird, you know,
considering the sizable overtly
racist individuals that,
you know,
I don't know what the fuck they were
here but they gravitated towards Trump.
So considering,
you know,
Brock being the first black
president to now let this guy into,
I dunno, according to
people I hear it. I don't,
I mean fucking looked it up
was endorsed by the client.
This is just fucking nuts.
Well that's it.
That was the end.
It's the end and now it's over and
now everybody can fucking move on.
And um, you know, I got, I,
I did Conan last night. I think a, I
think it went as well as it could have,
have gone and then of course, you know,
I get people giving me shit. You know,
I was trying to say, look,
whoever is president,
it's not really going to affect my fucking
day to day. And then of course you,
it's good you fucking white
guy over there. It's like,
yeah, I get it, I get it,
I get it. But your day to day,
your day to day, this is my,
and this is supposed to be
uplifting by the way. All right.
Knowing full well that the
world isn't fair. Okay.
And that some people start Waif
closer to the finish line than others.
That's just how it is.
All right.
And there's advantages and
disadvantages to that. You know,
if you got to run further, you always
think that other guy. Yeah, he's fucking,
he's all he's got to do is just fucking
go fright from there to there. Right?
And you see all these fucking rich kids,
they got drug fucking problems
because they have no worries in life.
That fucking right alerts
and all that type of shit.
Everybody wants to think if you filthy
stinking fucking rich that you just
skipped around and your
life is fucking awesome. Um,
I've done enough corporate gigs to see
that there's not a lot of happiness over
there.
They're fucking week really rich people.
I got to tell you out in Malibu,
you know, Neil always wants to go out
to Malibu. She loves the fucking beach.
And we go out there and his fucking, you
know, the seaside restaurants and shit.
You know, what's your cool, it's great.
You're fucking watch people surfing.
It's awesome.
He go,
you have a couple of crab legs and
then you get the fuck out of there.
But there's a mall over there. All right.
The Malibu Mall, whatever the fuck.
He go over there and I'm just telling you,
the people over there,
I cannot put my finger on it.
They are fucking weird,
really rich people. There's, there's
some sort of fucking disconnect.
I don't know what's going on with them.
They just, I said to me, I go, what?
What is, what the fuck is
with these people? There's
no vibe. There's no laughing,
what's going on? And she
just, she goes, the board.
Okay.
That's what it is. I Dunno.
I Dunno. I did gigs. Um,
um,
okay.
Way Back in the day,
I did some gigs out on the Hamptons,
another place with like super rich
people and they just fucking weird.
They'd sit there and they
all look at each other.
They're looking you up and down.
Like I showed up and immediately
they would just like, all right,
this guy's in here for the day is a day
tripper. So look at his fucking sneakers.
Uh, we'll get his fucking orange
Afro. Nobody has red hair.
Makes it in this world for them
at Donald Trump on the fuck.
Did he go from a Brunette to fucking
look in like me in seventh grade?
I don't understand it.
Um,
okay.
Anyways, but yeah, you, you make your
own fucking opportunity and I think, uh,
it's depressing is that, is it,
I always looked at that like a
okay.
I Dunno. I always try to see
like what the fuck I can do. Um,
I just can't believe the, all the names
that I'm hearing now, if Jesus Christ,
Newt Gingrich, Rudy Giuliani,
these fucking guys are coming back.
Jesus Christ,
that's like that Stallone movie where he
took all the fucking action heroes from
back in the day Seagal and they all
got to be level one last fucking thing.
Unless it's a head that will
make like three of them.
What was that called though?
Fucking last gladiator action.
Hero to fucking, I dunno, drink
your juice in the hood. I,
what the fuck would they expendables.
Yeah. This is like, he's bringing back,
this is like the Republican expendables.
He's bringing all these guys back trying
to think of another classic name he's
got to go for from way back in the day.
Somebody didn't die,
I dunno, whatever, but she
knows something. It's over.
Get on with your fucking
lives. And uh, you know,
okay,
there's all these protests at colleges.
I don't know what they're protesting.
I don't quite get it.
It's like there was an election.
It was legal and your person lost.
Um,
I guess they're just voicing
their displeasure with the
fact that this guy's in
there. I, dude,
I cannot fucking believe that the host
of the apprentice is now president of the
United States and that people
are this excited and hopeful.
Half the country is excited and hopeful.
You know what I mean?
Okay.
You know, the most amazing thing ever,
our broke ass people that are Republicans,
that's the most amazing
fucking thing on the planet.
So you guys in, guys, he's going
to make it great again for you.
All right? Please keep checking
in on me throughout the years.
I want to know how your life into
individually will become great again.
Oh, this country will become great again,
so then your life will be great again.
All those fucking people who
are gallop in sideways. Um,
okay.
I love how he wants to fuck it.
He doesn't want to have healthcare,
but he wants to build a fucking
wall from California or Mexico.
Oh, how much money is that
gonna fucking cost? Who?
The job that's going to create the
fuck Outta here? That's a death.
A government job. Do you know? Bet All of
these fucking, you know something. That's
one thing that they'll never police,
but that fucking bullshit.
Where these contractors,
they get these government jobs to build
shit and they charge 10 times the amount
that they should,
and these politicians just throw the
fucking money around and they don't give a
fuck, or they have to do it.
Whatever the deal is. You know,
like the math on this whole thing.
Do you realize like $7 billion was spent
okay
to get somebody a job that
pays 500 grand a fucking year?
You know why? Cause I bet it was, I bet
it was a bunch of people that build forms,
you know, foundations and shit. That's
what, you know, they were like, oh man,
I gotta get that. I gotta I gotta
build the wall, man. You know,
some go with the fucking rusted.
I'll pick up truck, dude.
If I get Jack Fuck a job,
oh I love problems are going to be over.
I'll be building that for
the rest of my life. Um,
what a fucking crazy God damn time.
You know,
everybody wondering how
the fuck this happened.
I think you know what it is is people
are still digging out of what happened in
2008 and it would have been nice if one
of these fucking pussy politicians would
have said something about the
fucking bankers, you know? Um,
I dunno. We will see what
happens, but uh, yeah,
boy. Oh boy. I'll tell you.
You know, it was great though.
It was when I went to go to the
electors to vote I fucking head.
I looked through all the fucking, uh,
propositions, everything. I had all my,
filled it all out,
like a fucking old lady.
And I went in there and I was just
like, Bang, Bang, boom, boom, boom. I,
I blew through the whole thing,
knew exactly what I wanted to vote for,
actually felt a mildly informed this time.
Um,
so
he just showed up in his own fucking
plank. This guy's a gangster.
I'm literally,
we shall see.
You know what's funny is my
wife had on MSNBC, by the way,
you know what I was doing
during the election.
I just kept flipping back and forth to
like, uh, who, if whoever was losing,
I would start watching them. I
would put on like CNN, you know,
I put head on Fox at first
in the beginning and once
they started looking like
they were winning and they were surprised,
then I went over to a,
the CNN thing and then I went
down to the comedy store and, uh,
did Doug Stan hopes live podcast and a I,
that was the most amazing election I've
ever fucking seen. That it was like,
it was riveting for hours.
It never got boring. Um,
and as much as I don't like
Trump, I didn't like Hillary
either. Uh, I have to say,
watching people crying,
um,
uh, white people, I wouldn't
say white people. If I see
somebody of crying, my God,
Jesus, this is brutal, but
just somebody white crying,
it's like I'm still white in America.
Um,
there was just something
funny about that to me,
like people hugging and stuff.
Um,
blew my mind, blew my mind. How many
people just still look at Hillary Clinton.
Like she's not a complete dishonest piece
of shit and like the best I could get
anybody to say, he's like, yeah,
but they're all like death. Um,
all right. Are you guys done? I'm
done enough with this shit. All right,
let's watch the gracious,
the Obamas, they,
where they shook hands,
they were very gracious.
And this is what makes the United
States, the United States, this,
this peaceful passing of power.
This is what makes the Americas,
the United States of America.
I don't know why this is like
such an amazing fucking thing.
This is just like just a different head
that's owned by the same what fucking 20
corporations out pill with your hacky
conspiracy theory. But isn't it?
Isn't that what it is?
Well, isn't it? Um, anyways,
let's move on everybody.
Let's move on to a little bit
of bread and circus there. Um,
so this, guess what just went on
sale? Everybody, um, as of yesterday,
promoted it on, on the Conan
show, uh, Conan O'brien show, um,
the fifth annual Patrice O'Neal comedy
benefit as always at the New York City
Center. Uh, tickets are already on
sale. Once we pay for the house.
All the money goes to his, uh, his
mother and his family. And, um,
it's been such a great event
that we do every year. And,
um,
and has had an amazing effect on,
uh, on people's lives that he
loved. It's been a great thing. And,
um, as I've said year after year,
the reason why we do whatever years,
cause I always hate when somebody,
somebody passes and it's just like,
you do like that one fucking benefit.
Like, okay, here's a sack, a loot.
I hope this will last you for
the next 60 fucking years. Um,
we all love poetry so much that we all
decided that we were going to do it every
year and um, make sure that, uh,
we continued to take care of the people
that he was taken care of and the people
that he loved. So, um, it
is, it is a great cause.
It is 100% honest.
It's something you can get behind.
None of the comedians are going to be
dressed in pink. None of that shit.
You know, it'll be a, it'll
be a great thing. And, um,
I'm also doing a, the comp come
home benefit with Denis Leary,
Cam Neely, uh, this
weekend and um, oh Jesus.
Oh Jesus did fucking Billy red faced
by some cigars. Holy fucking shit.
I've never a smoked these before,
but um,
I'm not going to tell you
where I got them. I'll see you.
[inaudible] I took a picture of him here.
I actually left them down in the
fucking humor. Do are there did,
why is this fucking phone
so difficult with me? Um,
a reality TV show star people with an
orange toupee is now going to be the
leader of the free world.
That's what you did.
And half of the country feels good
about us. I can't fucking believe it.
Uh, Jesus. You know what it is?
It's just none of it is really that funny.
It's just not funny.
The whole thing was just how to fuck
a on the right and the left people.
How to fuck did we end up with those two?
How did that happen?
I just kept thinking back, but like
all the fucking candidates just stunk.
God, they stunk. That cutie
pie in our camel hair coat.
The fuck is she doing now?
What are you talking about?
I'm sorry, I got an MSNBC here.
Where the hell is the God damn camera
here? All right. There it is. There it is.
Okay. It's Ah, fuck.
It's a blurry goddamn picture or
more old [inaudible] del I fuck,
I can't read it. I took a blurry
picture of it and then he thought if I,
if I zoomed in it would
somehow get better. Um,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
Sorry.
Sorry again.
The fuck is it? Oh, there it is. Okay.
[inaudible] de Monterrey Monterri Siri,
La Jolla and apologies to anybody
Latino listened to this 56 ring gauge.
It's like a fucking two hours smoke.
I got a fucking box of those God damn
things and bringing it to comics.
Come home and I'm hoping there's
going to be some cigar smokers there.
Um, oh, it's going to be such
a great event. Going to be
a great event. So anyways,
I have not been paying attention to shit,
uh,
been editing my new fucking special and a,
I'm probably going to add another fucking
standup date while I'm out here as I'm
waiting for my kitchen to get done,
which still has not done.
It was supposed to be done
by now, but then, you know,
we ran into the cloth
wiring, so, uh, you know,
and then the place we were staying
at the haunted fucking house,
the person won't, it came back. So
now we're, we're in a hotel and uh,
it has a little kitchen, right. So
I keep saying the Nia, you know,
it's fucking hilarious. It has this
little kitchen and as pots and pans,
but it has no spatula, had nothing
that you could fucking cook with.
It's hilarious.
They just had like the pants and um,
so I was like, oh, I see that fucking
game plan. They're going to act like this,
a kitchen and they're not going to
give me any fucking shit. You know,
they're gonna have a couple of props.
It's looks like a Goddamn
like sit-com kitchen.
They've got a couple of glasses up front
and then there's like nothing else.
Even the cereal bowls I like so
fucking shallow. It's like a,
it's like a deep plate, you know,
you pour a little bit of milk in.
It's already going over the sides.
So I drove back to my house and got all
my fucking tongs and spatulas and all
that type of ship. And now
I'm viewing it like, um,
I'm going to try to beat them at their
own game. Right. Because, you know,
stay in the hotels. Fucking expensive,
right? So Nia keeps filling an order,
goddamn room service. And I
keep saying to, I was like, Nia,
every time we eat in the kitchen,
all right,
the terrorist loose. Okay. This, this is
a victory for us. I fucking, I haven't,
I have not enjoyed food the way I have
when you are in a fucking hotel and you
actually buy food, you know, and start
cooking up, made eggs the other day.
Right? Simple Shit.
Just filling myself up.
I still got that fucking elk
that Rogan gave me. You know,
I made a little American shops,
so we with that shit. And um,
now my wife, she's telling me, let's go
downstairs. I'll meet you downstairs.
You know, they just love, like, women
are hilarious. They just love that whole,
the whole scene, right? Oh, they
kind like a fountain down there.
And you said [inaudible].
They have like a little tent.
His Nice.
Why don't you want to come to town?
We just wear you down.
Okay.
You just like quiz. It's like fucking
nine zillion dollars for fucking eggs.
I know, but it's nice. Fuck. All right,
fine. All right, here we go. The
NHL this without trying to get to,
we got the Columbus blue jackets,
all the, uh, the Boston Bruins.
Maybe I can finally watch a fucking game.
You know,
maybe at the fucking NHL network here.
Something
I don't fucking know.
I don't even know the folks on our team.
All I know is our first line as far
as I remember was Marshawn Burgi and a
pastor knocking. I don't know what
the fuck else is on the thing.
Bruins forwards d more.
No idea. Patrice Bergeron
back as we had last year.
David Cray, g Brad Marshawn.
Boleski sback Nash. I don't know
who the fuck that is. Jimmy,
Jimmy Hayes. Ryan's Buddha. T Shaller.
No idea. Posture. Knuck
okay.
Scissor. Nick Zernike. No idea.
Okay.
And I don't know anybody else.
Somebody's got Mila. CIARA McQuaid.
Okay. Both millers to crew, crew, expat,
both millers it back, crooks back.
Mcquade Shara,
I don't know.
Do we never fucking recovered,
man?
Whatever that fucking move was to free
up all the salary cap money. Yeah.
When we just basically imploded the team.
We're two years into this shit.
I don't know. It just
seems like it's, this is,
it's the same as like last
year as far as like the level
that we're at, where we're
going to, I don't know.
Joe Barton [inaudible] said it best.
He goes,
you did the worst fucking
thing you could do is you, you,
you missed the playoffs on the last day,
so he lost all the playoff
revenue and then you're going to,
and you're not going to be, you didn't
suck, so you could be like fucking,
you know,
Toronto and have a shot at
someone like a Austin Matthews,
you know,
whatever the fuck are you going to do.
As long as the Canadians don't win and
I'm happy, I'm a happy, happy fucking guy.
All right.
Let's read a little bit advertising
here and then I'm going to give you my
predictions for a Trump presidency.
What's going to change how
he's gonna make it great?
He's gonna make it great again.
All right. A legacy box, everybody.
This is,
this is the greatest fucking the world.
The legacy box. No legacy
is like pass down, right?
He's a legacy. All right? What was
the last time you watched home movies?
Your home movies.
If you're like most Americans as a
box in your closet of videotapes,
film reviews and photos that don't
get watched to taken out worse,
they are actually deteriorating.
Introducing legacy box,
a simple and affordable way to get your
recorded moments digitally preserved on
a DVD or thumb drive. Here's how it works.
Load legacy box with your old tapes,
films, pictures and auto audio
recordings and send it back.
You'll get them back in a couple of
weeks on DVD or a convenient thumb drive
ready to watch, share and
relive. That's pretty cool.
Just make sure if he did a personal porno,
you don't accidentally send that
legacy box takes care of everything and
provides updates that
every step of the process.
That's why over 250,000 families
have used them. The Huffington Post,
Bu Parents magazine,
USA Today and the view are
all talking about legacy box.
Even Disney has trusted legacy bogs to
digitize their media and for limited
time, go to legacy bucks.com/bird
to get 40% discount on your water.
That's legacy box.com/burr one more time.
Legacy box.com/bar uh,
with everyone gathered for the holidays
now is the perfect time to share all
those old photos and cassettes
and home videos. Go to legs.
We got lazy box.com/burry
40% off you fucking desk.
Count on your legacy box.
Did I mention it's legacy box?
All right. Joe Roberts
company, everybody, uh,
on and has a new product is
called a mulcify MCT oil.
Mct Oil is one of the fastest sources of
clean fuel for the body and the brain.
It's one of the best ways to power
up your performance at kickstart.
A weight management program.
Uh,
there's lots of MCT oil brands out
there are there, I've never heard of it,
but there's none a mulcify nonetheless,
like a mulcify MCT oil from Onnit
available in three delicious flavors.
Uh, the Billie red faced flavors,
coconut, vanilla and strawberry,
coconut head, vanilla
skin, strawberry pubes,
emulsified MCT oil mixes like
a cream easily in your morning.
Coffee without the need for a
blend. Beth, no mess, no cleanup.
You can even mix it into your
favorite foods right now.
If you go to [inaudible] dot com
slash bar, you can get on it.
So mulcify Mc tea oil for 12% off.
That's on it.
O n n I t.com/bill to get an
emulsified MCT oil for 12% off.
And for any reason, if you don't like
it, they'll give you your money back.
No questions asked at acts to asked.
You've got nothing to lose.
Go to on a.com now and get
on it. Alright. Oh Jesus,
one of our favorite.
Look who's bag good sold zip.
Are you hiring well?
Are you?
Do you know where to post your
job to find the best candidates?
Posting your job in one place.
While that isn't enough to
find quality candidates,
if you want to find the perfect hire,
you need to post your job on all the
job sites and now you can with zip
brewed up.com you can post
your job to 100 plus job sites,
including social media networks
like Facebook and Twitter,
all with a single click. Find candidates
in any city or industry nationwide.
Just post once and watch your qualified
candidates roll into ZipRecruiter's.
Easy to use interface, no juggling
emails or calls to your office.
Quickly screen the candidates,
rate them and hire the person fast.
Find out today why zip
[inaudible] has been used by
over 1 million businesses.
And right now my listeners can post jobs.
Does it?
Okay
for free by going to ziprecruiter.com/bird
that's ziprecruiter.com/bar one more
time. Hey, sip,
recruiter.com/burp. All right,
I guess we got a few more to go here,
but let's, uh, I'll break them up here.
You know,
again,
there's no fucking way you want to listen
to me to do six of these, you know,
in a row.
MMM.
Breaking news. Trump and Obama
meeting at the White House.
Yeah.
This fucking lady who's just moving her
fucking arms around talking, talking,
talking, shut the fuck. I got a lot
of nerve telling people to shut up.
MMM.
This is, you know, something.
This is going to be,
this is why is the right so fucking crazy.
Yeah.
What is wrong with you guys?
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
You pick the reality show TV star.
That's what the fuck you picked.
Then you pick George W. Bush.
[inaudible] can you give me a guy?
You know, this is what kills me
about you. Dumb fucks over there. I,
I lean right a lot. I lean left too.
Sometimes I'm liberal. Sometimes I'm,
but for fuck's
sakes, can you get me a guy
that could give a speech?
You haven't done it since. Herbert
Walker Bush. He gave a great speech.
I liked that guy.
I had no fucking beat with that guy.
Now I'm going to go from it
and cherishing hacker chick,
chick fucking eight years. Right? I
didn't like everything that Obama did,
but she got it. You'd have to admit
even you fucking racist comments.
Got To admit that guy was phenomenal
speaker, phenomenal speaker.
He is fucking hilarious.
He wasn't an embarrassment to hear the
world talk and now we're going to have
fucking Trump,
Jesus Christ.
Oh,
I got a lot of nerve cause I actually
liked Bernie Sanders watching that guy
give his speech. Jesus Christ. It
was like he was at a town meeting,
fucking hands flapping all over the place.
You know what?
I don't know if there was,
there wasn't a right choice in this one.
There really wasn't. All
right, now that the marines,
I know most of the two
best guys in the world.
Okay,
how do they think they got to have
now the, how the fuck do they do that?
Where they face each other?
They pause for a second,
right,
and then they put the same time.
They both fucking a, they salute.
Okay.
You know what I mean?
It's like you have a listen to
led Zeppelin and then they did.
They all just fucking, they're
playing, they're playing.
And then the song just stops and
then they come back in again.
And sometimes it's on time.
Sometimes it isn't.
And it's cause you know somebody just,
yeah,
it's a look that gives
somebody look and then boom,
you look at these fucking marine said
they don't give each other a look.
They still brought their fucking
hand up at the same time.
There's gotta be some sort of,
some sort of marine,
a little wiggle with an eyebrow.
Granted we are like 40 yards away with
the camera and then I'm sitting in a
fucking hotel room.
Okay.
I wonder what the fuck and
audition was to get that Gig.
Okay.
You know, how many fucking doors did you
have to open? Like perfectly to be there?
You know,
it's gotta be some proud mom out there.
That's my son.
He's going to open the door.
What was the last time a
president with the toupee.
Okay.
Was President.
They've all had full heads of hair.
All have full heads of hair.
Hey ladies,
who's going to be the next lady
president? I mean, the next,
the first one I should say.
Do you think Hillary's done?
Do you think she has enough pants?
Suits for another run? You know,
I dunno.
I just hope she goes to a chiropractor
and gets her fucking neck fixed because I
dunno. She was like a baby, you
know, I, you fucking, you know,
babies can't hold their heads up. She
kind of was fucking flopping all around.
Um,
okay.
I love the pants suit though.
You know what I mean?
If I was a fucking chick of a certain age,
you know what I mean?
I had the kids already,
you know, shut down
the park, if you know what I mean.
You know, hot flashes, a rover, right?
Wally world's closed for renovations,
you know?
Then you got to rock
the fucking pants suit.
You got to get the shorter fucking
hair. Like, I don't give a shit anymore.
You know, my husband's old. What's he
going to do? He ain't going anywhere.
And you go out, right? You get
the Ellen degenerates haircut.
He go out and you get a fucking pants
suit walk around and some flatties for
once in your life. You fucking
concerned about your own comfort,
you know? Ah Man. You know
what? If I was Hillary,
my next fucking move is what Johnny
Carson had his own line of fucking sport
coats. I would have my own line
of fucking pants suits. Right?
But you get people like Rihanna and
people in the prime of their fucking life,
they're like walking around half
naked and they somehow, you know,
they somehow turned the pants,
suits.
Who the fuck is is good looking enough
in their twenties to make the fucking
pants suit come back.
You know,
I, you know, I don't mind the pants
suit when I was coming up the fucking,
you know, Rhoda had them, Mary Tyler
Moore had a, you know what I mean?
And they will fucking young, broad sales
sitting there as a little fucking fire,
bald fucking freckled shirk off.
And I would,
why would watch all of those
fucking Charlie's angels that they,
we used to wear them for facet,
killed the fuck a pantsuit,
but the pantsuit back then was sorta
like the diversion of the John Travolta
suit.
You know what I mean?
It was just a bunch of ray on and
no condoms in the 70s and that's,
that's how we ended up where we're at.
It's why the fucking Rhodes
is so god damn filled up.
MMM.
Oh Jesus. To sound down
on em, MSNBC right now,
just looking at the
looks on people's faces.
I don't know why this shit is so funny
to me because I am not thrilled with this
guy being president. But seeing people
disappointed and crying on television,
you know, past, obviously if somebody
they love died or something like that,
I don't laugh at that shit.
But like I told you,
you guys way back in the day
when the biggest loser was on
and those fat people would just start
crying about how they could stop eating
hamburgers and shit. It
just fucking always, I mean,
I wanted them to lose weight and shit,
but this just something,
this sump did fucking hilarious about.
People cry,
adults crying. I don't know why.
It's probably me being a walled off,
you know, I'm actually, I'm not that
fucking walled up, walled off. Right.
I can get choked up with the best
of them, but if I did it, you know,
I expect people to laugh at me.
Um,
this is when you know you
have too much news coverage.
I'm sitting here watching this marine
opening and closing a door and these
fucking nerd guys keep
from the press.
Keep walking in and out of the shot.
Okay,
look at this.
There's a lady right now,
she's backing up to take a
picture with their cell phone of,
I dunno what now the marines
opening the door. She walks out.
Yeah.
You really,
you know what?
It was actually great that
she was in there just to see.
MMM.
Who the fuck just walked out of the place.
Okay.
What was that like?
His cousins or something.
Okay.
That's such a weird gig.
Does that mean you're a good marine?
But they make you like the fucking
bell hop of the White House. I know.
At the end of the day, I mean you went
through all of that fucking trainee.
You can snap somebody's neck,
right?
Can fucking shoot somebody from
200 yards away and then yeah. What?
What should detail? You can open and
close the back door at the White House
and then what? Nah, that's it. You're
going to be dressed in your formal,
so you're going to have your whites on
and you're just going to stand at fucking
attention though.
There's no way that anybody can do that.
It's gotta be like two hours shifts.
How long can you just stand there?
That fucking straight. Yeah,
but he's also got to be,
if some lunatic comes
fucking running up this,
remember that guy jumped over the fucking
fence and just ran up and he actually
got into the fucking White House.
That was unbelievable.
That's when I really realized like how
not important the president was. You know,
once again,
they don't even lock the door.
Yeah.
Do you understand that fucking ass all
who jumped over that gate and ran up to
the White House? Do you realize that that
guy got further into the White House?
Then he would've gotten into my house.
My door is locked.
Then he ran down the hall.
He gave a head fake and he broke the
ankles is some secret service guy. Right?
Like I ever sent did the Jordan,
when he first came into the league
and he wouldn't rent the, he got like
zigged instead of zagged.
And that was the only reason why he
didn't just fucking get in there.
Okay.
It's really not funny, but you know,
the fact that nothing happened,
that's kind of fucking
hilarious. Um, Jeez,
this cab with his pea soup,
green fucking tie,
just pointing and all that type of stuff.
He's fucking
cheese. Everybody thinks they
make it a point, including me.
Why don't I read the last few of these
things here? Um, all right. Wink,
pronounced wink. Stubby Z. All right.
Finding a great new wine is tough.
That's why I've been telling you all about
our sponsors at club. Debbie, a club,
WWI.
I wouldn't even know voted for Trump and
how they could make it so easy to get
wine personalized to your palate
and delivered right to your door.
And here's a little update we have
for your club, Debbie. Oh Jesus.
What are we going to do now?
This country's fucked is now called wink,
that spelled w. I. N. C. A
new name and an improved look.
But here's the important part.
It's still the same amazing wine
company introducing you to new wines.
You'll love a wink,
works directly with wine makers and
growers from all over the world to create
delicious wine delivered, uh, and
deliver it right to your door.
Winks 100% satisfaction guarantee
means if you don't like a bottle,
uh, they send you, they'll
replace it with the bottle.
You'll love no questions asked.
You don't just start,
you don't just get rich
sent random bottles. Winks.
WINC is a personalized wine membership
that recommends wine specifically for you
based on the results of your
palate and profile quiz.
You can also rate all of the
wine you receive from Winc.
So they learn about you with every order
and constantly personalize the wine
they send.
Sign up for Winc right now and gain
immediate insider access to the best fine
wine from all over the world.
Find out for yourself why yours truly
and thousands of other satisfied wine
lovers. I don't love
wine. I drink whiskey.
Why do they always make me do that?
I like booze. If you're into wine,
drink the fucking wine gives
me a brutal fucking hangover.
Why do you think they
switched it from club, Debbie?
I always liked it because I have Debbie.
You watched the cubs neon love me,
but they only love me when they
win. I can't understand it. Uh,
that's the best part. Winc is offering
my listeners 20% off right now.
When you try,
when you go to try winc.com try W
I n c.com/ [inaudible] all right,
they'll, they'll even cover the shipping.
Hey Lady, you know you'll love the wine.
Think about it. You'll get fine
wine personalized to your palate,
delivered right to your door.
Try Winc and get $20 off
and a complimentary shipping
right now when you go to
try winc.com/burger that's tried,
W I n c.com.
All right Hallux.
He licks your unique,
you know,
walk like anyone else,
talk like anyone else or
asleep like everyone else.
So why is your mattress
one size fits all well?
Cause the average height is
about five nine. You know,
probably that's the reason.
Most part we all have arms and legs
of fucking head on top of the torso.
So there's, you know, why are
all bicycles look in the same?
All right cause that's where you fucking
feet and your hands go up there and the
year because the truly co I,
I guess I was wrong because it truly
customized mattress will cost you five to
10,000 bucks until now.
Go to helix,
sleep.com answer a few simple questions
and they'll run a three d biomechanical
model of your body through the
proprietary proprietary algorithms.
I Dunno,
they developed with the help of the way
that'll make you a fucking magnus that
fits your body. The result is the most
comfortable mattress you've ever slept on.
A, isn't that right, sir,
sir? Oh, he's already asleep.
That's right. I have a random
person sleeping in here. A helix.
How customers report a 30% improvement
in overall sleep quality and for couples.
They customize each side of the mattress.
Your masters or your mattress arrives at
your door in about a week and shipping
is 100% free.
That's why everyone from Gq magazine to
Forbes are all talking about he likes
sleep. You go one, oh, you have 100 nights
to try it out. If you don't like it,
they'll pick it up for free
grouse and give you 100% refund.
No questions asked.
Go to a Heloc,
sleep.com/bird to get $50 off your order.
That's he likes sleep.com/bar
one more time. Hi,
helic sleep.com/bar is this
the last one? Oh, the last one.
I'm going to end with a little song here.
People to brighten your spirits.
That Oh,
boat boat.
These me. Andy, you
who elected Donald Trump. Odo Doh, Doh.
[inaudible].
Everybody take a dump.
They're nice and soft like is to pay.
Your balls are dry you and you say,
Hey,
what the fuck did we just do?
It was either the,
the clan or the clam,
but that was your selections this year.
The clan or the clamp? A
[inaudible] picture. A world what?
Putting a new pair of
underwear isn't just fresh.
You're stepping into a better day.
Think about her.
Underwears the first thing you put
on in the last thing you take off,
unless you were fucking Weirdo.
Uh,
why would you settle for anything less
than the best feeling underwear on the
planet?
Yonnie's focuses solely on producing the
most comfortable underwear you've ever
experienced. Well, that's what
you do. You make underwear.
What would you be doing now? What else
would you be doing? Huh? Make a diary.
I miss my friends at me undies.
These people I've never hung out with
who are somehow my friends send me a few
pairs a while back and now I can't
imagine it wearing anything else that is
alike. I where I'm not even wearing them
right now. Okay. But what they send me.
What comfortable except for the Greg
losing blue gain is cut. All right.
Was riding up on my bulls.
Yeah. Um, it wasn't even that.
I just, I just, I could not
wear them in front of my wife.
She was just dying laughing at me
as I was walking by. You're not,
I should have done, you know that
fucking crazy things at Olympic swimmers.
Do you know where they bend over and
then they just start fucking moving their
arms like propellers.
I want to do that next time.
Put It on my fucking my
Greg Louganis one's right.
I'm going to put on my swimming
goggles when my wife was looking,
I'll put on one of her fucking head Reps.
I'm just going to come out and do that.
All right. Sorry. Um, anyways, for price,
for the price of two cocktails me undies,
we'll deliver your new favorite pair
of underwear right to your doorstep.
Better Day guaranteed.
Try them on.
And if they're not the most comfortable
breastfeeding undies you've ever had,
the refund you and let you keep your
last pair for your first pair for free,
including the prices, the sweet touch, the
sweet caressing, touch of modal, modal,
a special fabric made with the best
in class raw materials that are
scientifically proven to be
three times softer than cotton.
These Uber Cozy undies are also sold
exclusively on me on these websites.
A website where you'll enjoy free
shipping in the U S and Canada. All right,
here's the call to action is the end
right here. And for a limited time,
everyone in my audience gets
20% off their first order,
but you have to go to our special URL,
[inaudible] dot com slash bar with
me undies. Better Day guarantee.
You have nothing to lose.
So don't wait any longer.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash per
right now for 20% off your first order.
That's [inaudible] dot
com slash burr alright,
and that is the, uh, that is the
Thursday afternoon podcast and a,
and that is the election. All right? It
is over. This is the guy that we picked.
And just because you know
your person didn't win,
it doesn't mean you got to yell at
other people. All right? You know,
it'd be great is everybody, if everybody
just sort of stop yelling at each other,
okay. You know, maybe help
each other out. You know,
somebody actually said to me, you know,
I'm a obamacare's going to go away.
How to fuck am I going to pay for my meds?
And that immediately made me think,
wow, you know what? Why not regular
people just pick up the slack, you know,
I dunno how to fuck to do,
it's what sets something up.
Or maybe you just help out one person
where if you're in the prime of your life
or your earning power or whatever,
you know,
and somebody down the street needs meds.
You know what?
If you booze a couple less times a fucking
month and you hook them up with some
money to get their
meds, you save, you want
and then you won't be as bloated,
you won't be drinking as much booze.
Why don't just regular people help each
other out instead of waiting for these
fucking people to do it because they
don't get along with each other.
Like when Obama went into office,
evidently all the Republicans on
the first fucking day in the house,
the Senate or whatever, just basically
said, we're just going to disagree with,
we're not going to pass
anything that this guy says, um,
which is really fucking
treasonous behavior. I think.
Not Saying you got to pass
everything that guy said she'd,
you do have to keep them in check, but
to, before it even comes down the pipe,
you saying, we're not going to fucking
work with this guy. I Dunno. Um,
so, but you can't ever expect
these assholes to ever get along.
They act like a bunch of fucking babies.
They really are a bunch of babies
the way that they behave. So, uh,
but that doesn't mean you have to
fucking behave like that. You know,
you could be a, you can be that
person who doesn't scream and yell.
You can be that person that doesn't
talk down to somebody because they don't
live near an ocean.
Or You could not judge somebody because
they do live near the ocean for whatever
fucking reason.
The blue states are near the ocean.
The other ones that fucking in the middle
and everybody's screaming and yelling
at each other. I have gone to
all 50 states and Goddammit,
I've met great people out there. I really
have great food, great fun. You know,
quit fucking yelling at everybody
and now you're going to be all right.
Trump's gonna be president.
For a lot of people,
I guess it will be a good
thing for other people.
It's not going to be a good thing, but
you know what? You're not going to die.
Okay. Get out in front of
it. Think something positive.
At the end of the day,
if you want to get your business going,
you're still going to have to do it.
Even if Obama was still in office,
a Hillary got, they're a fucking
newt Gingrich or Rudy Giuliani.
The end of the day,
your life facade you in life is not fair
and people don't have the time to give
a shit, you know? And that's
how it is. It's unfortunate,
but that is how it is.
But the second you fucking address that,
it's kind of empowering. Right? Oh fuck.
I gotta handle this shit. You know,
and this is coming from a
privileged white male, so,
oh, go fuck yourself. All right.
That's the, that's it. Okay. Um,
just trying to say shit positive.
Yes.
Ooh.
All right. Well then quit. Quit
moved to fuck Canada was sheriff.
See if anybody gives a
fuck. Um, anyways. Uh,
yeah,
yeah. It comes to music I
guess is what happens now.
And then we all get to listen
to some greatest hits before
the orange toupee guy was, he made
possible even running for president.
Who knows? Hey, who do
you think he, you know,
he should pick another reality TV show
star for his fucking vice presidency.
You know, he should get the
guy from survivor, you know,
who gets progressively angrier
with every fucking season.
I don't know if you guys have
noticed that. I don't understand.
Like I stopped watching it ears ago
because of it. He just like, you know,
red teeth
folly behind.
They got to step it up.
Just started fucking yelling at him.
He used to just be,
they used to be more exciting,
happy.
I think he's just sick of being out on
that island, watching people eating bugs.
I don't know what his issue was,
but he seems to be taking it out on the
people there in the islands, you know,
once they waste away. All right,
I'm done. Babbling. Alright.
You have a great weekend.
You're constant or does see on Monday,
Hey, what's going on? It's bill
is the Monday morning
podcast to what happened.
He yesterday, man, I'll tell you. Uh,
I was in a,
what the hell was I?
Fort Collins,
Colorado.
I was performing at Colorado
State University and I was
going to do the podcasts
from there, but every time I went
to call up I couldn't get service.
So that's what happened.
And right now I am in Indianapolis Cause
I'm doing Bob and Tom Radio tomorrow
morning to hype my Gig in Nashville.
All right,
so I'm on the road this week.
In fact,
earlier this week I heard
that I already commercial,
you know that Johnny Cash
song where he's like,
I've been to Tupelo stuff rattling off
all these cities happen everywhere man.
And I literally yelled,
I said shut the fuck up Johnny Silva.
So all right,
so have a lot of fucking people and
not to mention the fucking cities he
mentioned in that song.
Oh just a bunch of cities you
wouldn't want to go to anyways. Yeah,
I haven't been to any
everywhere you fucking redneck,
you should have said I've been to
Paris, London. You know what I'm saying?
Rome places people want
to go, not Tupelo, Toledo,
Charlestown. Nobody gives a fuck.
And what did you do that Johnny?
Maybe that's why you were so fucking
angry and that's why I'm so fucking angry
cause I had been in
those goddamn cities too,
when you know what I like about them.
Let's,
let's turn it around here and make it a
little more positive as I go on the 70
east trying to figure out where the
fuck up. There we go. There we go.
Um, you know, what I like
about them is they're a,
they don't have enough money
to Redo that downtown areas.
So you get to see what you know.
You know,
America used to look like,
like 50 years ago,
and I'm not trying to
be condescending here.
I actually liked architecture was better,
you know,
stuff was made out of brick.
Everything wasn't like a fucking
cheesecake factory and an Applebee's.
Anytime that's happened to me in my
life, I've been on the road. Hey,
good on the front desk.
Do you have any place where I can
get something healthy to eat? Um,
we have an Applebee's
that's a solution.
He wants something. KLC.
Um, what's healthy? Oh,
you know what healthy is healthy is when
they wrap the silverware in the Napkin.
That means you're eating healthy and you,
you know where they do that.
They do it at an Applebee's.
They do what? It's Shoney's.
Shoney's. I've never, um,
never eaten there and show me this
certain rest fucking restaurant.
You just go by those chains.
And for me anyways,
let me not speak for you. I don't want
to be arrogant here, but for me anyway,
some certain restaurants,
fast food chains,
I literally just look at the sign and it
gives me a stomach ache and I can never
eat there.
And Shoney's is one of them.
Steak and shake is another one
of the two of them. I Dunno,
maybe I'm combining and they have like
this orange fucking sign that just,
it just reminds me of what I'm going to
feel like after I eat that shit food.
But I'm not always right
cause I gotta tell Ya,
I avoided the waffle house like the
plague for like a decade on the road.
How would you see that
yellow sign with those?
Just that regular type script.
Waffle house and it just, you know,
you could just drive,
invite.
You knew how sticky the fucking
tables we're going to be,
how toothless the waitress was
going to be, how many felonies,
how many convicted felons
we're going to be. It's just,
it just wasn't worth it
to get fucking waffle.
Not to mention I have a
great recipe for Waffles,
but then,
you know,
when I did the rich bitch tour and
the two guys I was on tour with on the
Chappelle show one night to let's go to
the waffle house and I went in there and
uh, you know, wasn't that bad,
although I got to admit that it's
been so long since I'd been there.
Whatever they have their home fries
smothered, covered and all that stuff,
it's fucking gross. You know, I
don't like it. I don't mind you.
You're punching up the food a little
bit or kicking it up a notch is that,
it's going to say Harold Carmichael.
Why the fuck did his main pop?
What's that guy's name?
Emilio. Emilio Estevez.
What's the name of that
chef when he goes Bam,
he throws the sugar and
everybody goes fucking crazy.
Emilio Elios
I think the cell phone is affecting
my fucking memory. What is his name?
Jesus Christ. Uh, Emeril. Yeah,
we go Emeril Lagasse fuck the worst.
You know,
I was trying to remember the,
the name screech yesterday from saved
by the bell because I was talking about
people being able to sell tickets.
I couldn't fucking remember his name.
I was like scratchy, skippy, Sebastian.
I knew it began with an s,
some sort of continent afterwards.
Screech.
Okay.
What would you do if you are the
parent of a child star? You know,
besides steal his money before he turned
18 we'll put the fuck would you do?
Especially if,
I mean I'll,
I'll give screeches parents a break.
Okay.
But I've got to say from here on out,
if you put your kid into show business,
first of all, you're fucked
in the head. All right?
You wanted to make it on some
level. All right? And secondly,
if the kid books to
show and his characters,
his character's name is like
sippy. All right. You know,
just something you would name
a fucking ferric. If the,
if that's what his
character's name is or I call,
you just know he's going to be a
fuck up. I, why did I say Urkel?
Cause he's not a fuck up. But you
know what I'm saying? That point,
you got to stick that
kit and drug counseling.
You know when he's still eight years old.
Oh my God. You know, it tells
me a great fucking show.
You could have a scared
straight for a child stars.
What you do is you have whoever the
next fucking Hannah Montana is, right.
That's another one. You fucking
name rhymes. If finished,
she couldn't be on coke on her knees in
the bathroom of the viper room within
three years. I'll wait a minute.
But her dad's Billy Ray Cyrus,
so he knows he's been there. He's
the, I been there baby. Okay.
You understand whether my eyes look
and see the pain that is pain of,
of having a mullet and singing
a song called Achy breaky heart.
I swear to God. No, it was not
for five year olds. No it wasn't.
It was for adults who was for adults and
they fucking love it and they bought it
and then one day they figured out it's
stuffed and then they all acted lock.
They never bought it and no one
ever come to my shows again.
So I cut off my mode and I'm pregnant.
Did your Mama and then we had you.
Well now it's your fucking turn to
continue the legacy of horrific fucking
moments in show business.
Um,
oh, so this is the
show. You basically have
former child stars who've done drugs.
That dude from the courtship
of Eddie's father. Uh, yeah.
You have the dude Michael
Diamond. No. Michael Diamond.
Either the Beastie boys. Dustin diamond.
Yeah. Have him fucking in there.
Yeah. You know, you
have random Brady bunch,
but they never really did
anything fucking fags.
They never really did anything other
than linger around gaveled a boring cast.
The people, um, whatever. You just take
a bunch of child stars who fucked up,
who haven't died yet,
and then you bring them in there and you
haven't just start screaming at whoever
the next article is to make
sure he's not on drugs.
And if I could some how smooth
it out, I think I could, uh,
I could sell that show at the VH one. All
right. Stick a former rapper in there.
Get some hoes and you've got to show.
So you might be asking yourself,
Bill, you know, you've been doing
this podcast for quite a while.
You've been driving for quite a, I
don't shift your hotel yet. Uh, no,
I'm not because, um, I dunno,
I didn't want to spend the
night in Indianapolis even
though I have to do radio
tomorrow at six in the morning.
And I looked up,
I saw that the red wings
and playing the fucking, uh,
Pittsburgh penguins up in Detroit,
the best two teams in the NHL last year.
I pick a fucking,
I'll drive up the street.
It can't be more than an hour
and a half to Detroit. Well,
turns out it's three hours and hours.
He had a fucking car. So joke's on me.
This better be a good fucking
game. Um, but anyways,
I'm driving along here so
I don't have the questions.
I don't know if the question,
so all I can do it just run
my fucking mouth this week,
which I have done for nine
minutes and 51 seconds. What?
That also includes the intro.
I talk to that fucking machine every week.
Um,
all right, so this is a,
there's a waffle house.
Now I'm driving down the road and
I'm trying to make the decision,
the decision that Americans have
to make every day in this country.
How do I not become a fat fuck? I'm
a tie. It's very difficult out here.
It's very difficult.
Where can I eat at here?
There's a place called Joe's as
a throwback. What is this place?
Joe's Joe's crab shack.
Oh yeah.
That's what I do when I go
to the middle of the country.
Let me order some seafood show that's
fresh. No fuck is wrong with you.
I tell you know what we doing?
Indianapolis. We I sushi. We love it.
What do you have? What kind of
Sushi? What do you have? Trout Sushi.
So sort of Fred.
They have catfish Sushi out here. They go,
oh, we've got to go down there. We just,
can we just pull it out of the Crick?
Why does every moron in my
act have a southern accent?
I really have to stop that.
I'll tell you why.
Because every time you get
outside of a major city,
everybody fucking talks like that.
Everybody's got a little bit of a lazy,
Lazy Way of speaking that was awful.
Apartments every fucking
one looking the same,
but it's right near a manmade.
Like I got to tell you one of the
most depressing things ever for me.
Oh that's nice. We just merged down
to two lanes. Were there signs?
Maybe if I wasn't doing the podcast,
can you imagine if I actually caused
one of those horrific highway accidents?
You know, like anybody used to watch
that show chips, remember that uh,
Erik Estrada,
Larry Wilcox
that then private down the street and
their motorcycles and once you show they
would literally have a
20 to 30 car pile up,
which in all my years of being on
the road, I have never fucking seen.
And my favorite thing
about those pileups right
was they would last for like
a good fucking, I dunno,
one minute on television,
which basically in real life is like a
five minute catastrophe and everything.
When everything was all said and done,
there's like 25 cars upside down,
twist it around,
and it was always like an old oil tanker.
And then it was always that guy.
The last guy would always,
somehow he'd get air off of cars
rather than just plowing into them.
He just defied,
he would defy physics and he would somehow
get air shoot up and over everybody.
And if you listen to the audio,
for some reason the guy would
still be hitting the gas,
these literacy in the air
and his car's still going, Ra
like he thinks he's gonna make it over.
I never understood that even
as a little boy watching it.
And I look at my dad and I would say,
dad, why did he do that? And He'd be like,
shut the fuck up.
Just shut the fuck up.
And the cat's in the cradle and the seat
of a mood. Silver Spoon. There it is.
I'm telling you, I think the fucking
cell phone is affecting my memory.
So anyways, let's talk
conspiracy theory. Hey everybody.
How about that $700 million bail outs?
Is that autumn as an it made
the country a lot better.
He's fucking motherfuckers, you
know? I realized after eight years,
you know the outcast is, it's the
Goddamn bankers, you know what I mean?
Then more fucking terrorists than anybody.
You sons of bitches,
you know what they're
doing with that money.
Have they lowered interest rates
so people can get alone talk? No.
GM is going under. You know what
they're doing with the money for what I,
I overheard on the radio is there a,
they're using it to buy
up other failing banks
just inching us towards
the one World Bank.
That's what they're using it for and
they have the audacity to raise the
interest rates on credit cards to
help pay for this mortgage mess.
Then we just give you $700
billion to get you out of it.
I didn't know you were going to keep it
so you could buy more assets and then
further,
fuck me in the ass.
It's up to 27% on some people's cards.
Don't they have some sort of usury laws?
Does anybody who's remotely,
I want to say majored in economics
because anybody who understands is at what
point,
what percentage is usury?
There are up to 27% I mean,
back in the day did the mob even do that?
They own everybody.
That's what I realized when I really
looked at the whole economy that broken
everything down and I realized all
the money I've made in this business,
how much of it I've asked have I
ever held in my hand? You know,
I take out 100 bucks here, a hundred bucks
there. I pay everything with the check.
I get paid in checks,
just numbers on a piece of paper and I
kind of realized that even if I own shit,
they can still be seized
with the Patriot Act that can be arrested,
not charged it fucking waterboarded.
No,
I realize I'm going to grow a mustache
just in case everything waterboarding,
you know?
It's like there's still going to slowly
draw me right to hate water going up my
nose. It's going to grow one of those
big fucking 1970 sex symbols, mustaches.
You know, Burt Reynolds, you know,
it's got the best mustache ever. And
of course, I don't know his name.
He's a guy who was in the,
uh,
he was actually in the big Lebowski. He
was the narrator. Sam Elliott. I mean,
that guy's mustache. It's just,
it's fucking ridiculous. Number one,
a mustache wasn't cool for like 20 years,
but he kept his,
his was so fucking cool. You couldn't
question his mustache. He had,
that's like a man that's like a
fucking panning for gold and the 1840
[inaudible].
Then when the gold rush was anybody
listen to this from San Francisco and you
went out there and he sang
those awful fucking songs. Oh,
Mandar when Omen Darlin
Darlin Klamath time,
you got the worst fucking name in the
world. You must be in a good bitch.
Has there ever been a good
looking woman named Clementine?
You'll notice that there's like
hot girl names like Natasha.
I've never seen an ugly
girl named Natasha yet.
I've never seen a cool girl named Natasha.
I always just see some hot girl who
knows she's fucking hot at eight because
their name is Natasha, which ends
up making a B really, um, uh,
con to be honest with you.
Or is it more about me that I never had
the courage to approach a girl named
Natasha, Natasha. Fxe. Brooke.
That's a good one. Brooke. Natasha,
uh,
not Melissa.
Melissa's can kind of be down to earth.
Some sort of offshoot of Melissa and
I always notice was what the fuck?
I don't know Jesus Christ as if depressing
out here it is absolutely overcast.
I'll tell you, the Midwest Midwestern, the
summertime when all the props, you know,
waving in the air, you know,
makes you proud to be an American.
But when you're out here,
the beginning of winter,
you start to understand crystal meth.
I get it now I understand the anger of
slipknot. I never understood those guys.
Like what the fuck are
they so angry about?
And then I was in Iowa in like February,
and I was like, you know what? I get it.
I get it.
It's like a,
I dunno it, it really fucking
affects your mood. This is awful.
But those guys look like for you
guys in the side of the road,
then that's why those guys you
see on the side of the road,
you're not picking up litter. You
know, you're not mowing the grass.
You're not waiting to give somebody a
ticket, but you still got a little shine.
A little fucking siren on top of your car.
The neutral one though.
That orange one.
It's
like the uh, it's like the Jen
Brady of emergency vehicles.
Oh, the dad is super eight
motel with an indoor pool. Huh?
Who says this country and Trump
is in trouble. Why? They really,
they really stepped it up. They finally
living up to that name. Super Right.
Never Super. When I went to it,
there's a steak and shake. Next exit.
Oh, this is this part of the country.
For those of you who don't travel,
this is steak and shake.
Dairy Queen country
heartland resort camping.
Do you know I had,
I had a chance to go skeet shooting in
DC and I got so fucking drunk with Joe to
Rosa the night before. I couldn't
do it. Me and Joe to Rosa,
the guy I do uninformed with,
we are not good for each other.
That's what I realized when I
think when we're by ourselves,
we can make good decisions, but when we
are hanging out together, everyone else,
you've got a friend like that.
We're after a while, you know,
you just have to kind of tap out.
I'm not saying I'm not going to be
friends with Joe to Rosie anymore. I just,
I don't know if I don't think I
can hang out with them anymore.
Why are you driving so fucking slow in
the left lane with your high performance
muffler? High performance
mufflers. A ridiculous,
didn't somebody sends something
in about those being overrated?
It's fool little Asian girls and to
thinking that you have a fast car.
Bye.
You think it's an old guy with white
hair or is that a baseball cap?
It's basically a Honda
civic, early nineties. They,
uh, with the hatchback, it looks like
he's got some sort of erector set.
[inaudible] you remember that shit?
Nobody erector set us back when they
used to give you toys to try and make you
smart to give like a chemistry set.
Can you hear that?
Can you hear his car?
Whoa, Whoa, Whoa, Whoa, whoa.
Don't fucking 65.
He sounds like a motorcycle off in the
distance and he's literally fucking 30
yards in front of me.
Some physics major out there doing
the math right now to see if I'm not,
if I'm following too closely behind.
All right, so we're up to 20 minutes.
That's not bad. That's not bad. I, you
know, I, this is how I used to do them.
It was like an old school
throwback talking throwback. Um,
uh, I'm really going to be hating
this drive when I come back.
Do you realize that I'm such a mean?
Why doesn't this guy have a side
view mirror? Okay, here we go.
And I'm driving by him and
it is, uh, you know what?
It was a younger kid and he
had one of those, uh, you know,
the goatee where you
don't have the mustache,
but then you have like the really long
shit hanging off your Chin basically says,
uh, you know, I'm not wearing a condom.
Um, I dunno. Anyways, let's, let's
heighten my gigs upcoming this week. Okay.
If you've enjoyed this podcast
and you have a radio, I will be,
uh, on the Bob and Tom
Show tomorrow morning,
all across this great country of ours,
which is still great.
If we could get rid of these
motherfucking bankers. Um,
and I'm going to be
hyping my upcoming Gig,
the next gig on the uninformed
tour and uh, xannies and Nashville,
Tennessee. Um, this Thursday,
Friday and Saturday,
me and Joe to Rosa two man show.
We're going to be telling
some jokes or whatever.
And if you came and saw me last year,
I wrote a whole new hour people
in Nashville and listen to this.
I want to go skeet. Shoot. I
blew it in DC. I want to go.
I want to learn how to shoot something
that's my next puck and move as I plan
for the new world order.
Um, so come on man.
I'm going down to Nashville. I know it's
the music city capital of the world,
but God dammit,
just outside of it.
I know there's a bunch of people with
guns and he got fields and I want to go up
there and shoot a little plate just so
why don't you hook me up? I got, I got it.
Here you go.
Anybody who hooks me up takes me out.
Go skeet shooting gets a free three,
three,
three DVD.
Say That 10 times fast for you.
Your buddy you go hunting with and your
best girlfriend with them. Daisy Dukes,
motherfucker. I'm serious. I
want to, I want to learn. Okay.
Hey, it's his, his,
my latest fucking conspiracy that I know
they're going to combine this country
with fucking Mexico and with Canada.
Aside from the fact that they've got that
creepy commercial about how they have
a new enhanced driver's license that'll
make it easier to travel between the
United States, Canada, and
Mexico. Personally. I didn't
know that was a problem.
I don't know. There was people around
ego and you know, I love this country,
but I just wish it was easier
to go to Canada. God Damn it.
If I could just go to Mexico a
little bit earlier, I mean easier.
This is,
this is my big conspiracy.
I've noticed lately I'm traveling in
airports and all of a sudden there's this
new software out there
called a Rosetta stone,
which is a damn it,
I wish I looked it up.
I know the Rosetta stone is some sort of,
I don't even know what the fuck it is.
It's something difficult. Is it to like
the hope diamond? I don't know what it is,
but basically they took that name and it
is now it's software that teaches you a
bunch of different languages. Okay.
Which I always thought was cool.
I want to learn another language, but
nobody in America has ever given a fuck.
Now all of a sudden they're
selling these fucking things.
I was just getting off at the airport.
I can see if you're in New York,
if you're in loss hung delays.
We could actually speak Spanish
every fucking three feet I get it.
Or maybe French or something like that.
I don't know.
But like I just got off at the airport
here in Indianapolis and this selling the
resent of stone software.
Who the fuck in Indianapolis
is climber and to learn
a different language,
you know something's going on,
they're putting it in your head and
I'm telling you if you stick around,
stick it out in front
of people long enough,
they're going to this like Rubik's
cubes when you really think about it.
Was that thing fun?
It was kind of like a toy that was fixed
and you spun it three times and then it
was broken and you can never get it fixed
again unless you had an Asian friend
too for some reason.
Figured out how to do it.
I don't know what it is about those guys.
They just fucking smarter than us.
Is that like reverse racist in a way?
Because I actually said something fucking
you allowed to do that.
I know you're not allowed to say something
bad straight across about a race of
people.
Can I say something good?
The politically correct
police going to come at me.
Now that's just as bad because that's
offensive too. Stupid Asian people,
it's going to make them feel even more
retarded and we don't want that anyways.
Wow. I am really out here
in the heartland right now.
You know something people always say
that's the movement. Start a farm,
start a farm, save your money and that
type of shit. But as far as I can tell,
these farmers are fucked too,
cause they only grow one crop.
So what are you going to do? What are you
going to grow? Fucking corn, you know?
All right, you grow corn, then everything
goes down. You can't afford food.
Even if you've got well water on you, on
your fucking property, what do you eat?
Corn every fucking day.
Some point you got,
I guess maybe you can go out and shoot
a pheasant knows. Reminds me of a joke.
I used to wait at the hall of fame.
Any an Indiana basketball hall of fame.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Jesus Christ.
That's going to be the big
biggest collection of white
basketball players with
booty shorts in the goddamn country.
And you know, Larry Bird, he said Jesus,
and I can't argue with them,
Larry Bird. Now there is, it was,
it wasn't awful mustache.
He had a,
I have a cleft palate mustache. Ah,
Jesus, that was me. But you know what,
I actually bought one of
those kids in new smile,
so I'm able to do that joke.
Larry Bird had a fucking 14 year old
white trash mustache when he was like 28.
I don't think it ever
filled in his entire career,
that awful oval face. God
Damn. And he could play.
He could definitely place look at me
trash and one of the icons of Boston who
would have thought. Um, anyways, I'm going
to end this podcast this week with uh,
with the joke I used to do back in my
college days. It was back in college.
This is what I do.
All my college gigs,
standup gigs back before I
was doing mainly clubs. I
used to land at the airport.
I get around a car, you
know, grab a couple of cds,
possibly cassette tapes, depending on what
point in my career. And I drive across,
you know,
the farm lands out here in
the Midwest and I ended up getting a
joke out of it and this was the joke that
was like, you know, every time
you see farmers on the news,
you always see in pitching about how
difficult farming is. You know what?
I must've driven by 10,000 farms during
my standup career. And you know what?
I've never seen anybody doing shifts.
Okay?
Tractors always parked.
Cows are standing around,
there's absolutely no
fucking activity whatsoever.
And there's always a big satellite.
This there were in there
watching fucking ESPN.
And then when the media comes by and he
just smear a bunch of dirt on their face
and they're like, oh my God, it was good.
Try Food, jump on something like that.
And you know what?
Today is no different.
I just drove by 45 I have
not seen one fucking person.
The lights aren't even on there.
And then that happened.
Oh, I don't know what they do this time
of year. All the crops had cut down.
Who the fuck knows? But anyways, here's
something off all the people on my space.
I would really appreciate it if you would,
uh,
go on to my website [inaudible] dot com
and sign up for my mailing list because,
uh, I'm sort of inching my way over to
that one more so than the mindspace.
I'll still put shit up
on my space, but, uh,
I plan to start blogging and all that
crap once I get done with this uninformed
tour. A lot of, uh, putting some
extras on there because, you know,
I haven't joined Facebook yet and I just
really don't feel like going over to
Facebook and have to add the same 30,000
fucking people that I already have.
So if you go out on my website, then, you
know what I mean? And I won't spam you.
And plus you're also able to control
what sort of,
uh, emails you get from me. Like
when I said I was going to Nashville,
I just emailed people on
my Nashville list. Okay.
So you're not going to get a fucking
updates from me every week is I have some
sort of Zany picture
trying to utilize the web.
This is my one once a week thing that I
do, which I think is a good thing. Okay?
I usually do it on Mondays. I fuck around.
I give you a fucking free audio show.
All right? It's a lot more than, uh,
some of these other cons out there
doing right? All right, that's it.
That's the Monday morning podcast
on a Tuesday. I apologize.
I didn't get any cell phone
service. So, uh, God bless all ya.
God bless the United States of America.
Fuck the bankers.
Please go on the Internet and
start reading about banking.
Please read about it and just read
what the fuck over it is. And uh,
educate yourself with conspiracy
theory that is based in Wikipedia
and youtube videos. I just know
it's not all bad, everybody.
I don't like this. I'm telling you, man,
I don't like Internet gets a bad rap.
They only call the everything
on the Internet's a lie.
But TV's telling you the truth. Think
about the insanity of that. Man.
That's fucking ridiculous. It both full
of Shit and it's all mine throwing.
Fucking listen to me.
I have a good week and please,
if you live anywhere near Nashville,
please come down, come out and see me. Um,
and um, that is it. That's it. All
right, everybody have a good week.
I said that 15 times, God dammit. But,
uh, I want you to know I really need it.
I hope you have a great week.
God bless. Take it easy.
[inaudible].